to turn our attention to uganda which
has seen a spike in teenage pregnancy
since schools were shot due to the
pandemic rights groups warned that
lockdowns have exposed girls who would
otherwise have been in class to sexual
exploitation and abuse and unwanted
pregnancies
is 17 years old
and already has a baby
she was a student in eastern uganda
until schools closed last year to stop
the spread of kovi 19.
vaila returned home and then got
pregnant
i was afraid my mom was so angry with me
i ran away from home but returned later
while her school remained closed viola
helped her mother run a restaurant
that's where she meets the man who
impregnated her
viola's mother says that her daughter
was safe in school
if the schools hadn't closed she
wouldn't have gotten pregnant that's a
fact
this is viola school
like all schools across the country
it remains closed
and abandoned
the teachers here are worried that's the
more their students are kept from school
the more these teenagers are exposed to
abuse
during this time at home kids have
learned things that we didn't know about
at their age
remember this is a digital age where
children watch pornography on phones and
try out stuff
even the churches that would have helped
the children remain closed so many kids
are largely on their own
according to government figures before
the pandemic
one out of four adolescent girls fell
pregnant in uganda
this has grown to nearly one in three
girls in some villages
the unfpa also blames the growth in
teenage pregnancies on rising poverty
if like a girl doesn't have money to buy
cards for example and there's someone
who can provide some money for the part
then they find that they are vulnerable
those who are
poor they tend to
they tend to marry off the girls it's
like a business they when the moment
they matter of the girls
definitely then they get the bright
price in terms of animals in terms of
money
in uganda sex with a minor below the age
of 18 is punishable with a maximum
sentence of death
but the police say that
prosecution is challenging
victims are often compromised by
cultural traditions which mostly protect
the male culprit
we have a lot of cultural beliefs that
are very harmful
child marriage in some communities is
allowed
people think some of these cases are not
police matters
they don't even report them to police
they go they sit with the llc they
exchange
gifts
the government is now vaccinating
teachers to first track the reopening of
schools
viola hopes to resume studies but with a
baby to take care of
learning may never be the same for the
young mother